Speaker 1: I have disturbing video for you
today of Ron DeSantis appearing on Fox News
with a kid who says that masks are bad,
basically. And this looks like a hostage VIDEO.
It looks like, I mean, listen, I'm going to play
it for you. It's only 10 seconds will look at it
a couple of times. This looks like a hostage
video where the kid barely has any idea what
they're being forced to say. And Ron DeSantis,
Republican Florida governor, looks so smug.
Let's just look and listen to this. And then then
we'll see if we can make heads or tails out of it.
Speaker 2: Go ahead. I'm not wearing a
mask because you torture and you have
germs on your hand and then you put it on your
face and breathe in all the germs and and.
Speaker 1: Right? OK, and listen there,
Steve Doocy, I think saying, that's right.
Speaker 3: That's right.
Speaker 1: So this is Fiona Lascelles,
a second grader in Florida. And of course, when we
think about public policy, my instinct always is
ask one second grader what they think and make
that the policy. Now something about this video
is extremely disturbing, but many things
about the video are extremely disturbing.
Republicans seem to have found a way to put kids
front and center on masks and not wanting them
noticed that they never put front and center the
kids of parents who died unvaccinated of COVID.
I wish they got the same prominent placement as
Fiona Blackwell's saying I don't want to wear
the mask. Let's listen to it one more time.
Speaker 2: Go ahead. I'm not wearing a mask
because you touch her and you have germs on
your hand and then you put it on your face
and breathe in all the germs.
Speaker 1: And Ron DeSantis just looks so
thrilled. Now it's been. We have two options
we could ask a second grader handpicked by
Ron DeSantis their opinion of masks. Or
we could look at the studies endless,
endless, endless studies on this. Do face masks
work? 49 scientific studies explain why they do.
You can go to JAMA Insights. They have a meta
analysis called the effectiveness of mask wearing
to control community spread of SARS-CoV-2. They
actually look at all of these different studies,
and they find significant decreases in the
spread of COVID. You can download this. It's
a free study, you can find it, and they rate
increasing. Number of ecological studies also
provide persuasive evidence that universal masking
reduces the number of infections and deaths. These
studies don't distinguish the type of masks,
but they all seem to work to some degree.
The overall community benefit of
wearing masks derives from their ability
to limit both exhalation and inhalation of
infectious virus. The science on masks and then a
second grader hand-picked by Ron DeSantis. Sorry
about that. Let's let's listen to it one more
time. This is, is this child abuse in some way?
Speaker 2: Go ahead. I'm not wearing a mask
because you torture and you have germs
on your hand and then you put it on
your face and breathe in all the germs.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And that's importantly,
this is a second grader suspended 36 days for not
wearing a mask. One just little bonus clip for you
from Florida just to tell you how crazy things
in Florida are. This is 14 seconds of a video
of Ron DeSantis announcing he's going to create an
office to investigate election crimes in Florida.
What crimes are even being alleged in
Florida election crimes? I don't know.
Trump won Florida by three and a half. No one's
even really talking about Florida fraud. And
when Ron DeSantis announced so, so think
about the layers DeSantis mishandles COVID
announces he's creating an office
to investigate election crimes,
which we don't need. And then the crowd starts
cheering and chanting, Let's go, Brandon.
Just completely cringing now, if you don't know
about let's go, Brandon, it goes back to a NASCAR
race during which there were people in the crowd
during an interview chanting F Joe Biden. And
the reporter misheard it, she was interviewing a
race car driver named Brandon, and she said, Look,
they're chanting, Let's go Brandon. But really,
they were chanting, F Joe Biden. That's where it
comes from. It's it's not very funny. It's almost
like a rallying cry of ignorance and stupidity.
But when run, it's fitting that Ron DeSantis
announces an investigation into something we don't
need. And the crowd starts chanting, Let's go,
brand. And so just horrifying, horrifying stuff
happening in Florida. We've got a great show
for you today. Let me know your thoughts on
the DeSantis child hostage VIDEO. You can find me
on Twitter at David Pakman. We're going to take
some of your calls, look at some of your emails
and many, many exciting things happening today.
Remember that the David Pakman show depends
on the support of viewers and listeners
who sign up and get a membership
at join Pacman dot com,
we produce an extra show every day for
our members. It's called the bonus show.
It's won a number of awards. They are awards
I created. It's sort of like when Rand Paul
created his own ophthalmology organization as an
ophthalmologist, but much more moral. Let's put it
that way. Sign up at Join Pacman dot com. You can
use the coupon code better 21 to get a discount.